ah hello little boys and girls out there
welcome Janos rampage unfortunately
Santa got a little drunk last night
the hell is Oliver too much eggnog of
you know what I mean and then now all
those oil sands being forced to clean up
with own mess and no one tells ya know
what to do I unfortunately all the
little critters that are horn ormally do
my sleep why are shortly I don't care
about your God my face I sell clothes
although they don't read for you oh wow
look at those lazy little kids hole you
the stupid son of a [ __ ] why don't I
just write out there [ __ ] a linear
scan I can't read well sir I better get
to work
well then you bastard drunk so they'll
fill the base is that your boys no boys
here hotel pile of boulders over all
your bodies got mark in your back or
like you little can you just stop in the
back well I'm the entire time that I've
been hiring you
I'll give you free food flavor I'll give
you food bag oh man I'll give you free
jobs well I don't pay you for I love you
baby boy doing about it
oh talking about a polyfill you'll be
looking around so much
all right I got my bucket horse handling
the work yeah yeah public loses yours
yeah oh let it go got blown up and not
in the good way
well Tara respond because Santa can't be
killed by any normal birds
Oh Tara is gonna continue to clip yeah
dang it oh hello baby
if I was a very judge mrs. Claus oh yeah
ah just like everything I talked to I
spray with blood
oh well jingle bells go to hell I hope
you die today but I'm coming to kill you
and nothing you can say will stop me
little balls jingle bells
oh ho ho Lee's dead revertas y'all your
little can you are a pig
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm cleaning doctor change in his way
you weigh as much as I like my big
swinging balls that is not in the mood
for this sanity's to get some work or
the man upstairs is gonna be cut up that
was me
the lines that have we was made of a gun
with afters delivering all the kids to
the wrong houses the doctors on Mars
wanted presence of early nice guy you
are ugly asked it if it was your
kingsley jobs we bailed and your little
everybody's a you are one ugly mother
hubbard you her your life come fine in
the afterlife
yeah i don't really happen dead another
belong well yours are
all my magical scanner powers comes from
my hand of my big swinging ball
everyone knows the spirit of Christmas
isn't balls why do you think people buy
bottles of vodka waiver be their fire
[Music]
glue two dollars of goddamn bestir buddy
took my job took the love of all the
roads out here you got the titties while
Jay was your boy time to tell you to
care they're just jealous you can't buy
it cannot be I'll always don't he'll
further there's nothing like anyone but
I used to
[Music]
okay
Lucilla's care okay give it kitty
wotcher where'd you go don't run away
from yeah so is there you are sorry
so literally this how are you doing are
you still on the lap is you'll be
styling okay dad what sounds magical
powers don't work like okay I can't do
that it's do service I can't build a bar
I can't stay you breathe who can do that
you get to be blown up
I'm fine in the afterlife gonna help Dan
you're bald
[Music]
well thighs is faithful or the fires are
killing you deadfall you run those like
your big fun happen here what you see in
the blood
Oh 12 dead reindeer
I live the life for eternal misery and
pain where I can raise our voice harsh
or grave as shawls go [ __ ] yourself